well this is an interesting turn of
events lying Republican Congressman
elect George Santos is now under
criminal investigation you've got to
love it you know the I was thinking back
to earlier this week when he first
addressed his lies
the thing he was hanging on to was I
haven't done anything criminal remember
this clip
I'm not a criminal not here not abroad
in any jurisdiction in the world have I
ever committed any crimes to get down to
the nitty-gritty I'm not a fraud I'm not
a a criminal who defrauded the entire
country and made up this fictitional
character well fictitional or fictitious
or whatever word you want to use it
turns out maybe there is some
criminality AP reports New York
representative elect Santos investigated
for lying about his past he is now under
investigation by Long Island prosecutors
after Revelation surfaced that he lied
about his Heritage his education and his
professional pedigree as he was
campaigning he has shown no signs of
stepping aside even as he publicly
admitted to a long list of Lies Nassau
County district attorney Ann Donnelly a
republican said the Fabrications and
inconsistencies were nothing short of
stunning saying quote the residents of
Nassau County and other parts of the
Third District must have an honest and
accountable representative in Congress
if a crime was committed in this County
we will prosecute it what would be so
remember lied about his employment
history lied about his educational
history lied about being Jewish
apparently told the truth about being
gay and later I'm going to tell you he
apparently lied about his mom dying in 9
11. we're going to get to that that's a
whole other sick ordeal so how could
this be a crime yes in a normal job
where you're not voted in if you lied in
this way to Human Resources you would be
fired you would be let go but this is
different how could this be a crime in
this particular situation fraud is the
most likely charge so lying about one's
educational unemployment history can be
considered fraud if it's done with the
intention of obtaining a job or other
benefits it's abundantly clear because
he said it in an interview because of
the elitist New York Times not valuing
his customer service experience he
almost had no choice but to claim to
have worked for Goldman Sachs and
graduated from a college he didn't
graduate from he was almost forced into
it so he's essentially saying in order
to get this job
in order to get the type of coverage I
need and to get voted in uh I
embellished as he calls it we call it
straight up lying that meets the
definition of Fraud lying in order to
obtain a job or other benefits and by
the way it's taxpayer dollars that go to
pay his salary and those benefits that's
the most likely charge now in other
situations lying about your education or
employment history if you do it under
oath you're talking about perjury right
if you do it in a court case could be
considered perjury and then could have
legal consequences
discrimination if you lie about your
religion as he did and then that is
somehow used to discriminate or gain an
unfair advantage in certain situations
then it can be against the law and then
misrepresentation if you lie about your
employment history or your educational
history if it's done with the intent of
misleading others it can lead to legal
consequences including find and
imprisonment whether that would be the
case in this particular situation I I
really can't say we're kind of getting
ahead of ourselves but there's one other
aspect to the possible criminality and
it relates to some campaign loans George
Santos's massive campaign loans may not
be legal reports The Daily Beast and
here's the deal with that
um there are he loaned his campaign
seven hundred thousand dollars
it's not clear how he did it and as the
article says it uh it's been a bit of a
mystery
um but depending on how that was done
that also could actually be a violation
of campaign Finance law and uh the
article explains it in detail The Daily
Beast has part of an answer
um the identities of four of Santos's
corporate clients the Revelation puts
him in more hot water what he did with
the money he obtained could be even more
damning Santos has admitted using cash
from his company to fund his campaign
that could be an unlawful seven hundred
thousand dollar corporate contribution
that's because while candidates for
federal office may give unlimited
amounts of their own money to their
campaign they cannot expressly tap
corporate accounts to do so so that also
may be a criminal aspect to this entire
thing criminal is one part my hope is
that all of this gets him to resign and
say that he will not be seated which is
scheduled to happen next week we're
running out of time Republicans maybe
put uh Democrats plan to object from
what I'm reading Democrat Democrats are
going to object to his being sworn in
what that will lead to is a vote on
whether he should or shouldn't be sworn
in Republicans of course will have the
majority in in that new Congress but it
will put every single one of them in a
position of having to vote Yes this liar
fraudster should be seated or not that
could get very interesting we'll know
more about that next week
let's face it the holiday season can be
a stressful time for anyone even a
stressor on relationships in-laws
dividing time mismatched expectations
around gifts our sponsor paired is the
app that makes it easy to maintain a
feeling of connection with your partner
during this crazy time of year you and
your partner download the app you pair
together an everyday paired gives the
two of you questions or quizzes games to
have fun stay emotionally connected
deepen your conversations and all of the
exercises were developed by academic
psychologists and expert relationship
therapists as well my girlfriend and I
have been using paired quite a bit
lately it's fun especially with the baby
these days it's more important than ever
for us to find quality time and parrot
is really the perfect way to spark that
with funny moments meaningful
conversations and we can use paired on
the go don't let end of year stressors
get in the way of you and your partner
enjoying some connecting paired makes it
simple and giving your significant other
a paired subscription is a great last
minute holiday gift head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
trial and 25 off a subscription the link
is down below